top aides can't get off kamala harris's
sinking ship fast enough the vp's office
hit with yet another major departure
after three other high-level staffers
already said they are leaving this time
it's simone sanders one of harris's most
trusted advisors and top spokesperson
sanders reportedly steered kamala's plan
for handling the border crisis but now
she's hitting the road as it looks like
harris's presidential ambitions are
sinking the white house and kamala
defending that shake-up as perfectly
normal
is the vice president not satisfied with
the staffing that she has had so far or
do people just not want to work for her
anymore working in the first year of a
white house is exciting and rewarding
but it's also grueling and exhausting
it's natural for staffers who've thrown
their heart and soul into a job to
be ready to move on to a new challenge
after a few years i love simone and and
i can't wait to see what she will do
next and i know that
it's been a you know it's been three
years of a lot of
jumping on and off planes and going
around the country and
she works very hard and i can't wait to
see what she'll do next and i mean that
sincerely
jessie i mean that sincerely
when anybody says that that means they
don't like that's
i'm going to give you my best analysis
here there's there's three dynamics at
play one the mainstream media is
maneuvering the 2024
democrat primary and they're doing it in
the first year of joe biden's presidency
they're basically saying joe's toasts
this is how we're going to mess around
with the field in 2024 it's amazing to
watch this happen so soon and then you
have people that can read the writing on
the wall kamala's not the heir apparent
right so they're trying to get out
before the kamala stench sinks in too
deeply
these people a lot of them are about
resume building you know you know these
people you're in dc it's about you know
where you went to college who you work
for in the campaign what your title is
in the vp's office the minute it looks
like she's not going to be the one
they're out she's also pushing people
out and that's how she's done her
thing the whole time she's been in
public life whenever there's a problem
with her no no it's the staff's problem
kind of like me and waters world right
yeah whenever there's a problem that i
cause it's the producer's fault right
and that's what you're seeing and what
you're now seeing is the bench is so
thin with mayor pete and kamala it's
going to be like a
a bloodbath in a couple years because
you have i would say a
what a
gay white male intellectual
versus a woman of color and neither of
them can win the white working class
foot but neither of them can win the
black vote
so i mean this is going to be the most
delicious
divisive
drama you could ever imagine and as dana
says i'm here for it i'm here for all of
you great midwife
this is from jesse waters it's a miracle
johnny has not quit on you yeah well
he's not here today uh so dana you know
working in any administration is very
difficult it's stressful but as we've
seen over the past few months we've seen
a lot of reports leaking out about how
terrible her office is the people are
upset it seems like nothing really
happened to change that and now people
are leaving so yes if you think back to
the her campaign and then the the most
recent article the chaos of her office
seems to follow her wherever she goes
and you don't just have like a couple of
staffers on background telling reporters
they'll have 30 to 40 sources and so
then we found out in august that they're
bringing on a new image consultant and
then they remember that was when we had
the fake space video that with the child
actors yes and so there's it's been
building and i imagine a couple of
things first of all i think simone
sanders is way talented for her age
she's only 31 years old remember she was
also a bernie sanders person for a long
time and she she worked tirelessly for
him then in the 2020 election she
swallowed hard and said i actually want
to win and i think biden is the one that
can do that so she decided to go with
joe biden
now you saw remember she was actually
physically blocking him from protesters
at events right she was on television
for him every day doing a great job and
she was up for the press secretary job
did not get it and graciously went over
to work for the vice president i don't
know if they ever actually got to know
the vice president very well i don't i
that's one of the complaints that you
can read about in the multitude of
blind sources that happens in this um
administration however i would also say
this many times people who are big
campaigners they go into the white house
and it's like i don't like it because
there's such a straight jacket there's
all these rules and you have to be there
on time
there's no you can't like freelance and
be creative and that's really more her
style so she's got a big bright future
ahead of her i don't know what she'll do
with it but i think that it's probably
smart for her to leave when she is
jessica what's going on who's going to
replace all these staffers who are
leaving there are
plenty of people who want these jobs and
to do them for however long a year to
two years it's dana's the only one at
the table who's actually worked in the
white house but knows how difficult it
is
i'm sorry what administration were you
part of nixon i was young but i was
there
as his chief midwife yes
simone sanders i just want to double
down on what dana was talking about stop
it with the love fest people
i sometimes say that greg made a good
point too
simone is
so talented and the freestyling her
points that's when he'd hurt so great on
cnn as well after the bernie campaign
she became a pundit on cnn and she
really cuts the heart of what people are
thinking she expresses herself in a
normal person way uh fiercely loyal and
i do think that it's stung to knock at
the press secretary job after literally
blocking it and tackling for joe biden
but i do see this as normal churn and
then they'll have the midterm staff and
then they'll have that turn
this is like trump level no no it's
nothing is
close you never know maybe she'll be
back greg
i don't know man simone sanders probably
one of the greatest people i've ever
amazing i don't know how they're going
to replace her uh just a phenomenal
leader and uh just incredible i don't
know what else to say but what do you
know what are you gonna do if you're
offered that job now right it's like
that's like being asked to direct you
know the next alex baldwin western
no one wants it
it's very good it is incredible
what a disaster kamala has been given
that there really isn't any piling on
from the media of course there's us
having fun but from day one it was
always kid gloves right and yet with
that
it just shows you that you can end up on
the rocks if you tick all the boxes but
you don't think about who the person
really is and she's become a bastion of
a buffoonery even with people egging
cheering her on she's going to do good
she's going to do good the thing is this
could be a great opportunity for
somebody to take this job because you
can only improve it's like eric adams
becoming mayor after de blasio all you
got to do is appear normal
and try to make this person normal and
you'll be do a better job
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else